♪ (MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
When you're young,
it's-- it's really difficult
to articulate the feelings
that you have,
-whether it's anger, or love,
-(SCREAMS)
or just being okay.
The idea for the show
on a conceptual level
and on a visual level
is how do we allow our camera
to articulate it
for the characters.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
We want a-- a show that reflects
all the agonies,
the ecstasies that life can be
for a teenager in any moment,
but specifically, this moment
feels very fraught.
The world's coming to an end
and I haven't even
graduated high school yet.
For so long, we've seen this
kind of gritty, handheld way
of telling a story that's maybe
a difficult pill to swallow.
We wanted to move away
from that idea
and move into a realm
that was more expressionistic.
Sam wanted to-- to make a--
a show about teenagers
that looks like
how they imagine themselves.
(CAMERA CLICKS)
But at the same time,
you have to feel these
characters are really close.
So it's not about just
being cool or innovative
in a way, but more like,
being really personal.
♪ (MUSIC SOFTENS) ♪
If we gave ourselves more rules,
in terms of our color palette,
our camera, our movement,
it ultimately allows us
to be expressive without it
feeling like
it's gone off the rails.
It's essentially a deeply
experiential, altered state.
MARCELL RÉV:
He wanted to create a setting
that can be dreamy
but based in reality.
SAM LEVINSON: Marcell has this
very specific sensitivity
in terms of his care
for faces and people.
We dolly in and we push into
a close-up.
It feels like you're actually
breathing with these characters.
One of our challenges
that we were excited to meet
was what can we do
to make it feel alive?
How do you create a living,
breathing, pulsing world?
LEVINSON: How do we weave
all of our action
into a space,
and to accomplish it seamlessly?
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
Just the rhythm
of the show itself
is a percussive rhythm.
JULIO PEREZ: These varied
rhythms and textures make
any given experience
more interesting.
The rhythmic pattern
for someone who's dealing with
a really bad bout of depression
is likely to be very different
than someone who's thrilled
about
a certain development
in their lives.
I feel super lucky that I get
to play
with these different modes.
LEVINSON: Because the narrative
of it is so freewheeling,
it allows it to-- to go wherever
her mind wants to take it.
That's sort of how the scripts
and the stories unfold.
How would Rue tell this story?
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪